and other than that I've been in a
little depression I think because of my
excessive destiny playing I thought it
makes you happy it does make me happy
when I'm there but I get irritated like
if I'm in the car you know I just kind
of I think I'm gonna I'm addicted to it
yeah and not only is he addicted to it
but now he plays every night with my
best friend guard oh he's so I've lost
two people in my life I'm right here
Gardo doesn't text or call me anymore
yeah he just texts and calls Bobby the
lighthouse well he'll never go to
lighthouse but dardo is getting better
and he's been playing a lot like every
time I'm in space he's in space and we
meet and we have a good time and do I
feel guilty about it yeah but do I care
no I don't care I want him to be out
there yeah and if you're also checking
out if you're in any city go check out
my brother's band monkey hammer oh
that's right they're on tour yeah monkey
hammer calm I think is their website so
my baby you're 32 now I'm 32 yeah Wow
I'm glad you said that because I love
women ladies they lie they go oh no I
don't want to say I'm in the age why
would I lie about my age 32 how do you
feel as a 32 year old I threw my back
out yesterday yeah what happened with
that I was right there was a poster in
my sister ship my sister has a gym in
her garage and she had a poster of
jean-claude Van Damme doing a herkie in
bloodsport doing like the air splits
you know like in bloodsport and I
thought that I could do a herkie
and so I I threw my back out doing a
herkie I love bloodsport I was trying to
I was training for the kumite yeah she
came home and she was like my back hurt
it helped me out the car I need help out
the car
I threw it out so badly I can't bend
forward yeah yeah and I remember do you
remember Gymkhana too is that there was
another
we call Gymkhana bloodsport back in the
wind and damn no I think gymkata was
somewhat the other white dude but I
really liked those 80s
kung fu movies did you watch kickboxer
yes
yeah like kick bass American Indian job
next Halloween so tonight is Halloween
next Halloween you have to promise me
that you you'll dress as jean-claude Van
Damme in that dancing scene in kick
boxing
oh no I put a block know if they put a
blonde wig on and I'm doing that maybe
they think I'm like Gustafson or
something oh my god that's a bodysuit
and then some wide leg pants and you
just have to do the moves yeah how I
Bobby to go is Alexander Gustafsson
[Music]